ايديا من تطورات الحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه شنت سته عشره ضربه جويه
واكثر من 30 هجوما صاروخيا على مواقع
القوات الاوكرانيه على طول الخطوط التماس
الجنوبيه والشرقيه واضافت الهيئه وان
طائرات الاوكرانيه شنته 25 غاره على مواقع
القوات الروسيه من جانبها اكدت القوات
البحريه الاوكرانيه رصدها تحركات 20 سفينه
حربيه روسيه في البحر الاسود بينها اربع
حاملات صواريخها وفد مراسل الجزيره ان
مقاطعه سبارودجا شهيدها قصفا متبادلا بين
الجيشين الاوكراني والروسيه
كما تعرضت احياء في مدينه ادونيس لقصف
مدفعين اوكرانيه استهدف بشكل مكثف منطقه
كوبي شيبسكي وقالت السلطات المحليه ان
القصف خلف اربعه جرحه بينهم طفل وافادت
سلطاته عن تعرض بلدتي ماكيافكا شرقي دنياس
لقصف مدفع ولم يسجل سقوط اصابات بين مواطن
البلده